while the former president of mali is
held
under house arrest junta leader asimi
goyta in full
military regalia is sworn in as mali's
new head of state in what critics call
another bloodless coup outside the venue
special forces secure the area
the mood at the ceremony is somber
intense there are no heads of state and
few ambassadors
and some members of civil society
shunned the ceremony calling it
a sham and illegitimate in goethe's
first public address since last month's
coup
he sought to unite malians and tell the
world presidential elections will be
held
i would like to reassure the regional
and international community
in general that mali will honor all of
its commitments
for and in the best interests of the
nation
shortly after a new prime minister was
announced shogel maiga from the civil
society movement
m5 the west african body ecowas and the
african union
suspended mali after the military took
over and called for a return to a
civilian-led transition
there's concern about how the
instability in mali will affect the
security situation for the region
armed groups operating from inside mali
are launching attacks in neighboring
niger in burkina faso where more than
160 people were killed on saturday
it's in this building where simi goethe
was sworn in that
in 2015 a peace accord was signed
between the malian state and armed
groups now many malians fear
that the agreement is now in jeopardy
fearing the security situation
will deteriorate even further
france with 5 000 troops in this house
region which includes niger burkina faso
de mali has suspended military
cooperation with himalayan army
armed groups will profit from this
crisis in this political instability
there is a vacuum of power
and an absence of the state which armed
groups will try to fill
making it difficult for the peace
agreement to stand
echo says envoy good luck jonathan is
expected to meet mali's new head of
state
asimi goita on tuesday koita says there
is an opportunity to drive mali's
transition
towards the aspiration of the malian
people
it is a promise malian leaders have made
before
but have so far not fulfilled nicholas
honk al jazeera
bamako